so we've got a new president who exactly
is running the justice department we've
got some exclusive reporting on that
tonight in one of his very first
acts as president joe biden reported
appointed someone called nicholas
mcquaid to run the doj's criminal
division the all-important criminal
division
turns out that's the same criminal
division that's currently investigating
biden's son
hunter so who is this nicholas mcquade
exactly
well this show can tell you that he is a
former business partner of hunter
biden's new criminal
defense attorney a man called
christopher clark
hunter biden apparently hired clark in
december to help him with the federal
investigation
into his business dealings the criminal
investigation the doj is conducting
both mcquade and clark were law partners
together at latham and watkins they
worked on the same cases
right up until mcquaid took the job at
the department of justice
on january 21st of this year the same
day
nicholas mcquaid was featured in a just
department press release latham
watkins filed a motion in court to
withdraw mcquaid as an attorney he was
working on
with christopher clark so that
means joe biden put as the head of the
criminal division
the partner of the guy his son had hired
to defend him
against the criminal division whoa
we reached out to the justice department
for comment on this they refused to say
whether mcquaid would recuse himself
from matters involving hunter biden
and his former partner who was
representing
hunter biden it's all pretty amazing and
another reminder there's a lot going on
within the biden family we've got
another reminder today from
politico they reported this
joe biden apparently told his younger
brother frank last year during the
campaign and we're quoting
for christ's sake watch yourself don't
get sucked into
something that would first of all hurt
you end quote but by implication
would hurt me too too late now